have the government mandated coronavirus
locked down saved thousands of lives or
were they a terrible mistake that was
the subject of an online sohe forum
debate held on June 1st 2020 defending
the claim that the kovat 19 lockdowns
were the right move is Martin Macari a
surgical oncologist at Johns Hopkins and
the author of the 2019 book the price we
pay what broke American healthcare and
how to fix it arguing the other side was
epidemiologist Knut witkowski who's the
CEO of astera a company discovering
novel treatments for complex diseases
from data of genome-wide Association
studies Witkowski also served for 20
years as head of the department of
biostatistics epidemiology and research
design at Rockefeller University in New
York the zoom conference was
intermittently marred by weak internet
connection and audio lags meaning that
there were a few moments where witkowski
wasn't audible that we had to edit out
but thankfully the recording is mostly
intact so here it is
Marty Macari and Knut witkowski in an
online debate moderated by so of forums
director Jean Epstein
tonight's resolution reads the lockdown
has saved hundreds of thousands if not
millions of lives and spared American
hospitals the horrors of rationing care
speaking for the affirmative dr. Marty
Meharry a surgeon and professor of
health policy at the John Hopkins Johns
Hopkins School of Public Health speaking
for the negative dr. Knut witkowski
former head of biostatistics
epidemiology and research design at
Rockefeller University in New York guys
Marty and Knut when each of you has five
minutes and one minute remaining in your
allotted time I'll be briefly
interrupting to inform you Jane please
close the initial vote defending the
resolution Marty Macari take it away
Marty okay great thank you gene it's
great to be with you and I want to thank
the reason foundation and Jane here and
Nick and everybody you know it's too bad
we couldn't meet in New York not just
because New York is a great city but
because you've got a 30% immunity right
there which is highly sought-after so
thank you Nick and I hope all of you are
getting your hair cut scheduled we
consider a hair cut in surgery to be a
minor procedure so it should be
relatively safe so let me get into this
discussion here and it's great to have
canet who's really one of the great
minds on this topic
sharing the forum with me it's really an
honor I want to talk about what was on
our minds going into this pandemic you
know there were a lot of unknowns and
while we were watching Horrors take
place in Wuhan and in Italy we were also
watching sort of a general disregard for
this infection in the United States it
was almost as if the idea of American
exceptionalism crossed over into our
immune systems that is people thought
that we could
somehow fight the infection off with the
American immune system and that we were
resilient or immune or that we could
simply contain it early the reality is
that pandemics have a certain pattern
and as we saw this infection start to
scroll over towards the United States
there were a lot of fears we in
healthcare were concerned about
rationing at the doorsteps of our
hospitals if you remember we didn't have
good data going into this thing we were
told that the case fatality rate was
between one and three point four percent
and while we all knew there were more
sent a symptomatic carriers and those
who are also infected but simply had
mild or moderate symptoms and were never
tested it was an unknown we didn't know
if the number of confirmed cases
represented half one tenth or two
percent of the true number of cases out
there so rather than play horse betting
and everybody take an opinion and
estimate what they think the true
incidents would be in the United States
many of us took the approach that we
need to plan for the worst and hope for
the best
because the concern that what we saw in
Wuhan could happen in the United States
was very real we knew the Chinese
Communist Party was massively
underreporting both deaths
hospitalizations and infections in China
how do we know that because many of us
called doctors in China and asked them
what are you seeing on the ground why
have you stopped all transplant surgery
in the country of China to have only had
to have several doctors relocate and to
operate field hospitals Wuhan a city of
11 million had 19 field hospitals and
plans to build five more those 19 were
completely overwhelmed we heard from the
doctors directly so to think that simp
because of American exceptionalism there
was no risk of that happening in the
United States I think really was was
gambling playing with fire we had to
for what we were seeing there and what
we were seeing unfold in Italy for the
two months leading into this thing from
January 15th when the first case was in
the United States
walking on US soil all the way until
March 15th we saw very weak guidance
from the CDC we saw only a
recommendation to consider testing in
those who had recent travel to China
although we knew many cases came from
Europe through New York City we saw
guidance from Anthony Fauci really for
that two months only to say it's not
something we need to worry about right
now or to say that old people should not
get on cruises that was it for two
months January 15th to March 15th and
the media had every politician and
political pundit and strategist give
their opinions with little word from any
physicians infectious diseases
specialists
epidemiologists public health experts I
became deeply involved in this in my
capacity as editor-in-chief of MedPage
Today and in talking to the true experts
in biology and epidemiology and those at
my institution Johns Hopkins and
although I don't speak for Johns Hopkins
my opinions were informed by many of the
experts there it was pretty clear to me
that we were about to experience a
tsunami many of us reached out to Mardi
Gras South by Southwest the NCAA every
public event that we could think of that
had plans to having events with mass
gatherings all throughout what was
expected to be a major wave of the
infection we asked them to postpone the
plants some of them listened South by
Southwest which normally draws in
200,000 people from all over the country
and all over the world made a
last-minute decision really because many
people begged them to postpone it and I
think many lives were saved because of
that n-c-double-a did the same Mardi
Gras unfortunately did not and it became
a hot spot soon after the epic
make in New York City so we needed to do
all of these things not to be draconian
but to save lives we did not know what
we were dealing with we still are
learning from this infection so we did
what we needed to do calling for all
non-essential activities to postpone
their travel their gatherings their
business in person endeavours until we
could understand what we were working
with we needed we needed people to do
that to buy time we needed to buy time
not just to get to a vaccine that's a I
think a myth that's not the sole reason
to buy time it was also for us to
understand what the medical best
practices are that is what is this virus
how does it affect physiology and what
can we do about it well it turns out
that we're still learning even this week
almost three months into it how to treat
patients with illness from kovat 19 for
example we're learning there's a big
vascular component we started hearing
early on that there were strokes in
young people we heard about kovat toes
and in April there was a research study
in circulation research a publication of
the American Heart Association that
showed that 40% of all deaths from kovat
19 were related to vascular
complications this was a study done by
respected people dr. macra from the
Brigham and Women's Hospital Heart and
Vascular Center
he actually said and I quote if you
start to put all the data together
that's emerging it turns out the virus
is probably vascular tropic that means
it affects blood vessels the New England
Journal of Medicine had a paper showing
how it affects the lining of blood
vessels even though it's a respiratory
virus something is happening that we
have not quite identified in terms of
the mechanism even though it's a
respiratory virus there's an impact may
be due to a protein that it activates
that affects the vascular system this
has been a journey we have been learning
and because of it we're treating
patients better
you know a jamup paper three
years ago found that 79% of patients in
an ICU had blood clots that's new now
we're treating patients with
anticoagulation because we are learning
as we have bought time from flattening
the curve before we were not treating
patients with anticoagulants now we are
the vet the criteria to go on a
ventilator changed dramatically why
because we learned it's not a problem
with elasticity that is the stretch
capabilities of the lung tissue in fact
it appears to be some sort of problem
with oxygen exchange and while we don't
fully understand it it appears that
patients don't meet the standard
criteria to go on a ventilator and many
of them can be managed with supplemental
oxygen CPAP or BiPAP so all of a sudden
the need for ventilators dramatically
went down because we were learning we
learned about the cytokine storm and
even last week Roche announced announced
a drug called act Rima which is an
immune modulator and it is now in trials
we learned about the pediatric
conditions the post viral syndrome in
children we learned from the data we are
learning from the age distribution what
the true case fatality rate is it is a
destron out that for young healthy
people it's much lower than we thought
in fact it's hard for this virus to
really hurt someone young and healthy
and it does happen and young people can
be transmitters but we are now learning
the age distribution for example 43
percent of all deaths in the United
States from Cova 19 are in we're in
nursing home residents or staff we
didn't know that meatpacking would be a
hotspot meatpacking plants low income
housing where people are have a dense
population under a common roof people
with diabetes and high blood pressure
so we needed to buy time and because we
did we are much more successful in
implementing best practices in treating
patients you know we have about eight
vaccine trials now in human phases by
the end of the year we'll have tens of
thousands of doses and they
we'll be delivered by the end of this
calendar year according to the schedule
of many of these vaccines probably a lot
more that will help that will help
increase the amount of immunity that
already lives in certain parts of the
United States so we're learning a lot
and patients are doing much better
because of it so I would ask you in the
spirit of this discussion would you
rather be sick
early on when your doctors knew little
about the infection or would you rather
be sick now when your doctors know a lot
more about the condition and are
reporting much better success in
treating it we were on the brink of
rationing and while we were buying time
to understand this condition we were
also buying time to develop therapeutics
but we were buying time to avoid the
risk of rationing New York City was on
the brink of rationing doctors some of
whom were already burnt-out dealt with
incredible things that they had to
witness there are even stories of
splitting ventilators but they were on
the brink of rationing care they were
told there wasn't enough PPE we were
told that ships in China with PPE were
told not to leave their harbors we were
told in the United States to stop
elective surgery something that I do
because we were gonna burn valuable PPE
and if the surgery wasn't essential to
hold off that's the situation we were in
people forget that we also did what we
needed to do to stop super spreaders
that is things like one person in a
church giving the infection to 60 plus
other people that was documented in
Washington State meatpacking plants
similarly we know now mass gatherings
and high-density are big drivers we know
the high-risk groups we know we've got
to protect our nursing homes we're
learning about the impact of heat and
climate so stopping super spreaders is
something we could only do with the
information that we have gathered you
know in the Spanish flu during that time
there was a debate whether or not to
send more US troops to
Europe to fight the war the doctor of
the president actually urged the
President President Woodrow Wilson not
to do it arguing that the infection
could cost a lot more lives than anyone
appreciated well on March 11th in 1918 a
cook in the army named Albert Gitchell
in from Fort Riley Kansas was sick and I
gave in five minutes Grant five minutes
God he gave the infection and I'm gonna
try to show you here what happened he
gave the infection to what ended up
being 522 individuals he went on this
one he went on one of the crowded ships
over to Europe after Oh some of the army
soldiers
522 of whom got infected went on this
crowded ship to Europe in the end the
most common cause of death among
soldiers in World War one was not
bullets or mortar shells it was the
Spanish flu stopping super spreaders is
something you can only do with data look
I was one of those people that called
for a closure of non-essential
activities but now we need to change our
strategy our strategy needs to evolve
there's a lot that we can do there are
papers now coming out suggesting that
what we did save lives as a matter of
fact at the time it was controversial
but now it was well recognized that
super spreaders had a major impact on
mortality in World War one in fact the
doctor and the army
basically assured everybody's saying
infectious diseases that formerly took a
lot of lives have all yielded to our
modern knowledge of their causes I mean
look at the pride in this comment this
is the Surgeon General of the Navy and
that there were you know because there
were
measures taken for their prevention I
mean that is sort of the misinformation
that needed to be challenged at the time
and I think we need we were challenging
at the time of this increase at that
time Philadelphia had basically no
precautions taken to stop the Spanish
flu but st. Louis did a lot and you can
see the results of both cities here in
terms of the number of cases one
completely overwhelmed the local
hospitals and doctors and the other was
able to manage it with an overall lower
mortality rate on April 14th of this
year there was a study published by
researchers at the University of Wyoming
looking at the number of lives saved
through a controlled approach and they
showed that it was much less on average
reducing contact and transmission by 38%
and they argue that the peak was reduced
in half another study that came out in
the National Academy of the sciences and
in full disclosure I'm a member of the
National Academy of Medicine looked at
in Europe the reduction in cases due to
taking severe medicate mitigation steps
and finally looking at the travel and
resultant transmission in China because
of the lockdown researchers have
described that there would have been 65%
more cases had there not been a lockdown
now if you think about it
China had breakouts in Wuhan and Harbin
those are cities of about 11 million
people China is much larger China is
over 1.1 billion how is China able to
move on and manage the infection after
massive outbreaks in two of their cities
and it's because they took it seriously
and engaged in a shutdown for a
temporary period of time and because of
that
they were able to manage it I would
argue they were also able to manage it
because of masks distancing and good
hygiene and as someone who went mad one
minute left two more to go
when someone who called for a closure of
non-essential activities I'll be the
first to tell you that closure has had a
death toll and it's not a death toll
that anyone should take lightly we were
worried about rationing we were worried
about people dying on the doorsteps of
hospitals we were worried about what had
happened in lombardy and Wuhan happening
in the United States we asked people to
do it on a temporary basis but as the
data has come in our strategy needs to
evolve and unfortunately I think we live
in a polarized society where people dig
into their positions it's often fed by
the media sometimes by politicians and
it's been disappointing to watch this
issue get political become politicized
I've got about 15 seconds more
everything changes everything changes
and we need to evolve our strategy and
that's why last week in The New York
Times I wrote a piece calling for a
reopening but for us to reopen carefully
in a way that still respects the
dangerous nature of this virus so with
that I'll say thank you and looking
forward to the conversation Thank You
Marty okay
your next opposing the resolution with
Kowski take it away canor okay I will
argue and I will try to do that based on
papers that I have published and I will
give you the sources so that you can
check it yourselves that what people
were hoping for didn't happen so the
lockdown was based on bad science and
unity is already widely spread and now
we have more deaths drop losses and
since a few days ago massive social
unrest and there will be never a second
wave hospitals are not
the risk of becoming overwhelmed so
there's no justification anymore to
continue the lockdown and it should be
ended immediately there's no need to
have it lingering on as I mentioned this
the results of that I present here were
published end of March and in part based
on the data we have from South Korea
which is 51 million people and until
today they had only 260 death even
though they had no settlement but you
will see on the right side are often the
references so when you see this you can
check what I did so I published in end
of March and but at that time we already
knew in New York
the horse was out of the barn we had
substantial positive testing all over
New York in particular in Brooklyn and
the Queens up to in some areas more than
50% of all tests we're positive so there
was no way we could contain that and
still at the same time thought she said
now starting in March 31st there were 30
days we would have to slow the spread of
the epidemic there was a gross
misunderstanding of the dynamics
actually two weeks later at the White
House meeting Robert Redfield one of the
Hib
scientists in the team presented data
and when I saw the graph that you see in
the background I couldn't understand why
people they're not jumping to their feet
because it was a extremely important
graph and here it is in more detail this
was the smoking gun what we see here is
year by year the curve of people showing
up in emergency rooms with
influenza-like infections the first peak
this year in red
was influenza B and of December the
second B was influenza A in early
February and the third peak was Kabat
nineteen mid of March now for to show up
in an emergency room on March 18th the
infection must have been occurred at
least 10 days before the incubation
period and then you are not going with
the first symptoms to the emergency room
you're making a couple of days and maybe
you see your physician first and if it
doesn't get better than you don't so
what we see here is that the peak of the
number of infections was early in March
and fating down the country later two
weeks later when the number of
infections was already way down E is
useless it was as in Rossini's opera the
barbier
of samaria a useless precaution so
thesaurus cough to infections peaked in
early March the models that help us to
understand so that in the beginning of
the epidemic in blue on the left side
everybody is susceptible and then
somebody red infectious into the
population and for about two months
nothing happens and then suddenly we see
the first cases indicating that the
number of infections must already have
started quite some time ago and the
number of infection goes up until the
number of immune people and most people
become immune after getting infected is
as large as the number of susceptible
people in the population and at that
time the curve turns down and the
epidemic ends this is what all
respiratory disease epidemics do and the
week or so late after the peak in the
shoes there is the peak of their cases
in yellow I said red before some people
think this was orange and now gay allows
in other cases and gray at the bottom
the death so this is a normal
respiratory disease epidemic it happens
with all of them and eventually we end
up with a lot of people being immune
which gives us long hurt immunity for a
couple of years now if we would do after
the peak some intervention reducing the
transmission we will not flatten the
curve we will actually sharpen the curve
because we're already at the peak we
cannot flatten it anymore we will make
it a bit more narrow we will have a few
fewer deaths but it will come at the
price and that is we will have hurt
immunity at the lower level and the next
epidemic is coming earlier but the
difference is not big and the difference
in the number of cases is totally
irrelevant so we cannot save our
hospitals by doing an intervention after
the peak of the number of infections has
already occurred so the locked on came
too late
to flatten the curve now fast forward to
where we are now the hospital ship that
was in New York where a thousand beds
left in April 26 because it wasn't
needed
there was the hospitals were not
stressed to the level that they would
need additional capacity the the deaths
came a bit later as one would expect
that and if we overlay the data in New
York in the data that Robert Redfield
presented we see that it all nicely fits
the epidemic was essentially over as far
as the infections are concerned in early
April so the battery we see the effect
of community a bit earlier
that is at the inflection point where
the inflections don't increase anymore
but start to slow down this is where
epidemic where immunity starts to kick
in and when we are looking at when did
that happen and we're looking at the
hospital admissions or the ER visits
when you see that this epidemic became
young Internet immunity kicking in that
this already happened even earlier in
March or maybe in late February so even
more evidence that at the time in
mid-march when all these interventions
and restrictions started it was futile
in the meantime what you also can see
here now at the end we are already way
down the number of case there are no
more hospital admissions for Cabot the
critical care beds are not utilized over
utilized anymore
at least not by Cabot what we're seeing
is not only covered it's also other
diseases and the number of tests has
dropped dramatically right now less and
5% of all people tested in New York down
from 70% less than 5% show up with
positive test results and they're mostly
in hospitals there were elderly people
and nursing homes and other places so
from all of that data we know that there
were no ii-era business for Cabot's by
children this is here at the center it
says 1 to 17 this was another epidemic
where children showed up but Kabat was
it it was in commad the spread in does
slowed from early march much earlier
than the intervention started the US
hospitals will not be overwhelmed there
is no risk anymore whatever and there is
no circulating virus in New York City
since about May 1st
why then continuing the lockdown now you
have seen
such curves is the second HIV expert on
the task force explained she said well
we have to flatten the curve to reduce
the number of aces well here is what she
is presenting and that is a
misunderstanding of what is happening
when we are intervening in an epidemic
because we cannot make it intervention
because before the epidemic is later but
even if we start and that's on the right
side very early before the number of new
infections Peaks then there is still
there's a lower curve yes but that curve
as soon as we stop the intervention then
we will have what people thought the
second wave because we haven't reached
her immunity and it has hurt immunity
that stops the spread and nothing else
so that's what people thought might
happen but they forgot that the
intervention didn't happen early enough
for that ever being risk so there is no
concerns necessary about second wave or
the need to drag on as people have
written feared for years the new normal
we can go back to the old normal and
then can we can learn whatever we want
from the experience
so because the lockdown did not flatten
the curve there is no risk for the
second race in fact we now know that
when we are testing in New York for
instance many more people are still
infected so the lockdown has not stopped
infections and if we look into Europe
so I mentioned South Korea before now I
mentioned in Europe including Italy we
see that in all countries in Europe the
number of new cases is dropping
dramatically the number of cases all
over Europe is now one per 100,000
people per day and that is a drop in the
bucket
it doesn't make in Germany for instance
and a population of 85 million people
there were eight thousand five hundred
deaths that is less than car accidents
so neither in Europe nor in the US did
the lockdown have a major effect on the
spread of the virus but it had
substantial side-effects one was already
mentioned and was a bit more
conservative here as said at least 30%
of 100,000 deaths in the u.s. occurred
in nursing homes why well it was this
totally exaggerated number of nu
Ferguson and the United States the
United case in the United States Kingdom
that protected 15 million
hospitalization and would have been much
too much for 1 million hospital beds so
it seemed that flattening the curve was
necessary but England would not reduce a
number to what was needed so starting in
late March New York State for instance
mandated that nursing homes set covet
positive cases in order to reduce
pressure on the hospitals well in fact
increasing the number of increased sin
member of cases because it increases the
number of secondary cases in the nursing
homes and has increased the hospital ICU
use why did people send back the
infected patients to the nursing homes
the New York State issued an executive
order that was pulled from the web but
of course you cannot delete anything on
the web so you find even the things that
the governor mounts to it as not to see
and there it's stated that there is an
urgent need to expand hospital capacity
in New York State to be able to meet the
demand for patients will come at 19
requiring acute care so it was the hype
that created the dangerous situation
that patients who were infectious
stable were sent to the nursing homes
where they could infect all the other
people in the nursing homes so it was
the fear behind the lockdown that
actually increased ICU used and cost 30
more than 30,000 death so the other
consequences are also severe but good
thing is air quality was better so the
lockdown was really good for air quality
but other than that among the elderly
with comorbidities was so higher ICU use
and more deaths but then we now see
riots and as of today 11 people died and
I'm sure there will be more deaths
medical treatment for surgeries chemo
therapies and organ transplants was
delayed and caused death in many cases
people are avoiding emergency room
visits we had suicides from bankruptcies
and depression we have more homicides
and 50% of all children were not
vaccinated so they will have life
threatening diseases later so I've tried
good to walk you through this
step-by-step so this is not an opinion
that I have these are effects and you
can look them up I gave you all the
references so the infections peaked in
March early March
long before the intervention started
there was no flattening of the curve
there were no ER visits for carpet by
children the hospitals will not be
overwhelmed there is no more circulating
virus at least in New York in another
states many other states and than others
the situation will be the same very soon
there is no risk for a second wave that
was all based on a misconception of the
epidemiological modeling because they
ran all people involved in epidemiology
in the knowledgeable of respiratory
diseases in the task force there is no
infection significant effect on the
spread so in summary
the lockdown increased that I see you
use and increased the number of death by
more than 30,000 and so I think the cast
of thousands of life we're in Cree it
did cost tens thousands ten thousands of
lives increased hospital utilization and
therefore it was not such a good idea
quod erat demonstrandum what I wanted to
prove so we have the difference I have a
few minutes so I would like to have less
than a minute all right okay all right
so that concludes a case for the
negative Marty we now go into rebuttal
phase Marty McCarrick you have five
minutes to release your rebuttal take it
away Marty okay well um Thank You c'n
eight knut you're um you're a good man
and that was a great presentation
I think there were a lot of truths and
in it and I agree with what you said
that there is no longer a need for a
lockdown because the lockdown has had a
heavy toll on health outcomes we know
the biggest driver of health status and
health complications is really
socioeconomic status and as we some
families are pushed into poverty that
has an impact on health suicide rates
child abuse calls to the child abuse
hotline in Washington DC or up 77% new
cancer patient visits not follow-ups but
new cancer visits are down 30 to 50
percent in New York hospitals so I agree
there is a heavy toll that we pay for
having a shutdown and that's why I've
called for us to reopen carefully but
remember going into this thing for those
weeks that we were going into this thing
we didn't know and we still don't know
what did we prevent what did we avoid
and I do think the severe mitigation
steps that everybody took as we began to
understand this disease medically and
epidemiologically did have a positive
impact but we were on the brink of
collapse of some of our infrastructure
we essentially shut down the healthcare
system in New York City and in other
parts of the country New York City had a
co vyd only healthcare system where
unless you had some other emergency it
was only accepting really CO vid
patients or other health emergencies
that was pretty remarkable for New
York's healthcare system to be on the
brink of being overwhelmed and the the
Cova Depa demmick is not over and i
remind people that make conclusions that
it's still ongoing let me share with you
a quote from the mayor of Montgomery
Alabama from ten days ago
okay we're in June right now this was
just ten days ago as you know Montgomery
Alabama despite it being in the Sun Belt
had an outbreak not from nursing homes
and meatpacking plants sending a lot of
cases to the patients to the hospital
but instead routine regular daily
activities the infections has spread a
Montgomery Alabama and the mayor told
NPR ten days ago we are in a health care
crisis quote unquote we are short on PPE
if you need an ICU bed you're in trouble
he reported a few days later that they
were out of all ICU beds in Montgomery
Alabama hospitals Montgomery Alabama is
still dealing with an outbreak and while
it's not everywhere and some of the data
that dr. Burks and dr. Redfield showed
are its aggregate data from the United
States if you look at a particular area
or an area that's been hit hard and
let's face it this first wave has had
many waves within it depending on region
some areas did get hit extremely hard
we know that second waves
happen we know they happen with some
infections by the way dr. Frieden the
former director of the CDC said today
that he expects another 20,000 deaths in
the month of June so it's still ongoing
you know we were hoping hoping that this
was going to be more seasonal that he
would have a greater impact in
mitigating the infection through
increased humidity or through the direct
UV light or the fact that people in
warmer states tend to do more things
outdoors they may have less public
transit they may be less congested than
the states that got hit really hard like
the coldest of the states were the
longer cold season and an increased
density like New York City Chicago
Detroit but the reality is that Hong
Kong flu had a second wave h1n1 died
down in the in June and then it surged
back up again in the fall and luckily
it's contagiousness was lower but second
waves do happen and my concern is that
we had this corona virus with
essentially one third of our cold season
one third of the winter imagine next
cycle we have the corona virus with the
entire effort one minute America and
influenza which could be a mild moderate
or severe influenza season and
potentially had no available therapeutic
at that time so I am concerned about the
second wave and I'm hoping it's not
going to be as serious resurgence I'm
very much hoping that it's manageable
and I believe it will be manageable in
other words I don't think we'll need to
go into another extreme lockdown but I
do think in the bottom of my heart that
when we look at the hospitals that had
that were overwhelmed and on the brink
of rationing and hospitals that
essentially transformed into kovat only
hospitals plus emergencies that the
measures that people took early on were
helpful during the incline you know we
all thought we'd have a rapid steep
incline what we call a symmetric
epidemic curve
a steep rise and then a steep decline
attention dad
we saw a more prolonged stretched-out
decline and a longer stretched out
plateau plateau and maybe that's due to
variations in the adoption of the
mitigation but that's perhaps one of the
reasons why we're not at the point we
were hoping to now as we reopen Thank
You Marty
and now ignite you have a five minutes
for your rebuttal take it away hood I
understand that this epidemic was scary
and that there are lots of things that
trigger emotions especially when you are
scared
I don't think however it is wise to pick
individual localized events for a
national strategy let's take the
hospital in Montgomery Alabama this same
article said that the reason for that
they were over thinned fill it is that
the hospitals in the surrounding cities
didn't open and so everybody else from
the surrounding cities ended up better
this is something that can be avoided
without shutting down keeping the
country shut if they're the whole story
as I try to explain of the second wave
they are no second waves with
respiratory diseases we haven't seen any
second wave so far anywhere with this
one and the last one was in 1918 19 and
this is because the virus it's something
very onion it started mutating and
something that was not recognized by
crossing the ring they have to go back
to always is very very real and not
something we could need to think of
and we have very positive events we're
both in China actually end in South
Korea we had two typical ways of occur
a symmetric but every similar and that
is a thought
[Music]
of the united states of keeping and more
and more of the negative side effects of
the shutdown should not be indoors we
should reopen as is and deal if there
should be a problem let's deal with it
but not let's not drag on something that
is known to be bad you can go to that's
it spend more time no not at more time
and I would say one more thing we have
as epidemiologists we have always
advocated to isolate the vulnerable but
here something entirely different was
them for the first time ever and it
failed badly we have isolated the
healthy that does not make sense it
would have been before that made a lot
sense to isolate the nursing homes we
could have saved tens of thousands of
lives if the nursing house would be
isolated as people have done that for
instance in South Korea and that the
unite this is the failure of the United
States if that had been done we wouldn't
have needed anything else could you want
to tell you're certainly something you
froze a little bit your audio was not
perfect I know what you can do to adjust
it your end but just wanted to tell you
that um so for what that's what but I
mean you you came through okay but
whatever you can do to improve would be
good so you could note you're hearing me
you've concluded you I'm hearing you all
right you seem to be coming in well now
a bit and you were okay but but just a
little concern so what am I apologize to
everybody who couldn't hear me well yeah
well indeed yeah sure that that's uh
your apology is accepted do what you can
to improve we now go into the Q&A
portion of the evening and the a
prerogative on the part of the moderator
me as well as prerogative on the part of
either debater applies to ask a question
of the other
and you can you to connect sense that
prerogative in any time I'll press
connote do you have a question to put to
Marty Marty do you have a question
Marty what do you want to put a question
to morning Marie why do you think that
the epidemic of 1918 19 is so important
now a hundred years later when we have
antibiotics and we are not at war
that's great question yeah I think we I
do think we can learn from history I
think if you look at what happened in
1918 there were a lot of commonalities
for one essentially every governor in
the United States in 1918 assured the
population that there was nothing to
worry about that it was under control
that it was essentially almost finished
the infection had run its course and
during the entire pandemic now there
were assurances given and that's what I
find so ironic about the quote from the
secretary from the Surgeon General of
the Navy suggesting that in 1918 you
know science and medicine and best
practices and public health strategy had
modernized so much that there is
essentially no appreciable risk of the
infection we did see a denial early on
with this infection and the reason that
some of us took to the airwaves and
decided to start writing op-eds talking
about this posting on media and going on
television is we generally felt that the
guidance we were given was not
sufficient and that we were
underprepared if you think about us
going into the shutdown mode the
shutdown of non-essential businesses it
was a last-minute scramble it was
disappointing it was entirely
unnecessary to be scrambling so that
people were driving home from work
hearing that their state could be shut
down and racing to the grocery store to
get groceries well we've been watching
this thing play out since December in
China and I don't know why anyone
thought with three flights a day leaving
Wu hen province for Europe that we
thought somehow this this was going to
be
we knew the characteristics of it
although we didn't know the distribution
in case fatality rate so so I I do think
that we can learn from history
I would I would ask dr. Witkowski if
perhaps he has some comments and I asked
this sincerely and I like I said I I do
agree with a lot of what dr. would
Kowski has been saying especially about
the need to reopen at this point
carefully given the toll on public
health but but can you comment on Brazil
Brazil right now is seeing a raging
infection they're still on the increase
that is they're on the incline of their
epidemic curve they have over a thousand
deaths per day for a country that's a
little larger than half the size of the
United States and the scariest thing to
me is that it's very warm that we
understand this to be a seasonal
coronavirus like the other four
coronaviruses that circulate year to
year there is a seasonality we saw the
South and Sun Belt got hit less severe
than projected but in Brazil part of the
country is on the equator and it's very
warm and they're getting hit very hard
right now is wondering if you could
comment I can answer the question I
don't want to implement in Brazil
because I don't have enough information
about Brazil and I have one of the
people who talk when they know something
and otherwise they shut up okay okay
passes on the question no but I want to
I thought I could make a comment instead
okay you have is also related to what
Marty said and that is during the
discussion in March
not a single epidemiologist was ever
heard in the United States and like him
as a surgeon
we as epidemiologists have also tried to
be heard but being more theoretic nobody
wanted to listen it everybody was in
tuned to hear horror stories that had no
justification and left the country into
a situation where the cure
was much worse than the disease okay I
want to step in and ask and take
moderators prerogative to sort of take a
deep dive into what seemed to be the day
that that you've submitted unit for
consideration by us all including of
course by Marty you claim though to to
have data taken from the Center for
Disease Control itself showing that and
let me verify this showing that
nationwide hospital visits peaked on
March 18th and from that you infer that
infections must have peak days earlier
new approximately at the eighth
and so that's nationwide data that's
foot and then secondly you infer from
that that since the lock downs occurred
about starting the week of eighteenth
that the lock downs started too late to
flatten the curve
first of all coat is that a fair summary
of the data you submit and the inference
you draw but could you tell us that
first good okay first is I am NOT
claiming I'm just interpreting the data
that the head of the CDC Robert Redfield
presented on April 17th and I'm inviting
everybody to take a look at the data yes
okay it was not about hospitalization
and I did not say hospitalization
I said hospital visits I suppose it is
it to the ER room yeah yeah so that is
it is one of the problems that ma week
as precisely as it's necessary to
accurately assess the dangerous that we
have if you talk of death rates and they
don't talk about it don't say is it the
infection or the case fatality rate is
at mortality overall it all of these
words have a meaning and if you miss use
them you get yourself into a lot of
trouble
okay is that all good what I hospital
visits and you inferred from the
hospital visit speak that the that the
infections happened something like ten
days earlier and I suppose 10 days
before ten days before March 8th is what
you said and I and I believe that you
are interpreting that to mean then that
that since the lockdowns occurred of
about starting about the week of March
18th
this is nationwide data that you that
seems to be the linchpin of your
argument that the lockdowns came too
late to flatten the curve is that a
correct interpretation of what you're
saying this is one of the data sources
pointing and then I provided other data
sources that confirmed this result that
does not mean that there is not in some
other parts of the United States where
we have very lower number of cases that
the dynamic might look a bit different
but this is what we can say about the
whole Northwest and this is more than
50% of all AIDS sorry of all cases in
the United States okay this has to be
nationwide data okay Marty is there is
there do you have any so again good idea
security is drawing that inference Marty
do you have any response to that
particular set data claim and the
interpretation that connect places on it
sure first of all I do think that
hospitalizations is perhaps the most
powerful metric and the one that I track
most closely if you look at Texas for
example there are areas of Texas for
hospitalizations right now if you look
at a seven day moving average are on the
rise Alabama Wisconsin Minnesota
tragically where there's been riots
related to the recent incident there so
I do track hospitalizations as they go
up in the case positivity rate goes down
that usually means that there's more
testing available I just want to point
out that dr. Witkowski raises a good
point
we did not hear enough from
epidemiologists and this wonderful form
that you have here Jean to talk about
these issues is exactly what we should
have been doing as a country instead of
listening to all the politicians and
pundits with no background in biology
public health medicine epidemiology or
anything health care they were talking
to the country for two straight months
from January 15th till March 15th and
all we heard was was sort of the party
line and people's guesses as if they
were horse betting we should have been
having this debate ahead of time I think
the data was convincing enough to say
that the the realm of possibilities was
concerning enough that we should
temporarily either stop or reduce
non-essential activities and then once
the data was in once it was clear that
we had sort of past the point of
potential rationing which happened
relatively soon it happened in April
then we could go into the mode of
learning from the data to change our
practices we told people for example to
stay at home we probably should have
told them to be outdoors
we told businesses to close we probably
should have told them to distance and
wear masks we told schools to close we
probably now that we have the
information looking back we know that
the risk in schools is primarily to
at-risk teachers and that the risk to
children rivals the same risk of viral
meningitis for regular seasonal
influenza in that age group when there
are no other risk factors so look we
gave out blanket recommendations because
we didn't have the data as the data came
in our strategy needs to evolve and
because it did not evolve quick enough
it did not respond to the data quick
enough and the data that did not become
available promptly we have paid a price
because of strategies that have lingered
okay okay Aman Thank You Marty I want it
then pick up and what Marty said Marty
Marty could you address the specific the
guts with this data point marty is
talking about hospitalizations I know
you plan a graph on that so you you have
issue about hospital visits to emergency
rooms hospitalizations and then
infections could you Marty is saying
hospitalizations is the key data point
it to interpret could you address that
specific technical issue take it away
it depends on both are important it
depends on what it is you want to learn
from the data so I wanted to learn from
the data
when did the infections happen and the
hospital visits are close to that if
therefore and they are also data that
are unbiased because they were collected
every year without any question of
testing and anything so we get early
unbiased data and that is better than
the later biased data but I want to pick
on one thing that Mario said and he said
even pointed to mid-april and even
though epidemiologists would never ever
at least not people who are reasonable
epidemiologists would never ever have
quarantined the healthy and let the line
or a boat ran around and actually
instant fact that is a no-no among
apologists they would have said we can
learn from China and from South Korea
that we have to protect the elderly and
shut down nursing homes and not the
schools schools yes all right okay I
want to do when I would pick up on
another key claim and then first we'll
run it by you
and then then get Marty to respond you
were claiming that if I understand your
Corinne that that that the hospital
system was overwhelmed and you were
focusing specifically on New York's
New York because as a result of the
policy all people with the virus were
told to go to the nursing homes and if I
followed you correctly
they then infected a lot of other old
people in the nursing homes which in
turn meant that all of those old people
infected the nursing homes were
overwhelming the ICUs
so you seem to be claiming that the
overwhelming nature effect correct with
that less from the note from that effect
of the public does that summarize
correctly your what you were saying look
fat the overwhelming of the hospital
system especially in New York yes do you
have a response to that particular point
morning oh look if we look back and
identify the key mistakes that we made I
think one of those key mistakes is that
we failed to protect nursing homes we
should have made them bulletproof we
should have undergone the strictest
protocols you could possibly imagine to
those that were extremely high-risk and
not only that when an an outbreak starts
in a nursing home that is an opportunity
to respond and so the the nursing home
story it will end up being I think one
of the great tragedies of this and I
hope that this will address one of the
ales of our modern society and that is
how society has for decades been oddly
complacent with the problem of influenza
deaths each year because that problem is
very similar and is managed in a very
similar way so I hope that is one of the
silver linings of this pandemic but do
you agree with the canucks
argument that the lockdown itself
especially in New York cost cause the
policy of driving the old the sick old
people to the nursing homes which in
effect overwhelm the New York City
system because they had to be treated at
ICU
do you see the relationship between the
locked nursing home problem which the
morning do you see that relationship or
do you just sit from it had I not sure
about what was happening in New York
what I do know is that patients with the
infection were sent to nursing homes
that should not have happened and that
patients in the nursing home that we're
sick were often sent to the hospital
when
potentially they could have been managed
differently in isolation I see okay and
then finally the the the good news which
could has stated but but perhaps not as
as triumphantly as some of us would like
and listening to what he said is that we
have achieved herd immunity and cannot
since you're the one who claims we have
achieved her to me first of all what we
pretty much nationwide you're claiming
that in most areas of the US including
New York City herd immunity has been
achieved the good form of herd immunity
reasonably long lasting and first could
would you define for ignorant folks like
me exactly what you mean by herd
immunity and then will you tell me
whether you believe it's been achieved
before I give it back to Marty
take it away hood okay hey if
substantial proportion and mari refer to
that the substantial proportion of
people got infected and survived which
means they are now immune like that
every other respiratory disease and that
means anything else that would come that
virus will have a very hard time
spreading if it can at all there was
another aspect and that was mentioned
very early on by the Oxford group in
London and that is Gupta
the elite scientist she said that she
thinks that up to sixty percent of the
population could have crossed immunity
from exposure to other coronaviruses
in the years before and it it now seems
that her position was correct so that we
now have not only the 30 percent we see
when we are testing but actually more 50
60 maybe 70 percent of people are immune
and you're saying and if I understand
you but when you get to that threshold
connotes then what then the other 30
percent well including it as long as you
protect they're really frail people
they're not going to catch it and why is
that good
well the virus dies off if the virus
cannot find any people to it infect the
marker simply disappears and at that
point the elderly people can bear come
back and meet the very grand children
and children and be back and they have
there's no risk anymore because the
virus is not there anymore
and we already see in New York how
rapidly the circulating virus new
clients and and you are and you are
saying again to put a fine point on it
you say we can we can ironically be
thankful that the government was late in
in imposing a lockdown because had they
been early we might not have had the
degree of herd immunity we have seen
that so that's so we can ironically be
thankful for the ineptitude of
government the server lining that
ineptitude which is quite a few wonder
if the government does the wrong plane
in a better bit for the government to do
the wrong thing later than earlier which
is what you said has happened so North
gets in very neatly to a fantastically
optimistic outlook and now I want to
turn it onto over to you Marty to maybe
strike a pessimistic note Marty please
take it away how do you respond to what
could have said well I'm an optimist by
nature so I'll do my best here that to
explain what I think is true to the
science so there are unknowns and there
are known and I think what we're
discussing are some of the remaining
unknowns I personally look at the data
and believe that because we engaged in
mitigation because of the secession or
postponement of non-essential activities
that we were able to buy more time if
you look at the way this infection has
spread around the world we were able to
buy time and we're still buying time in
many parts of the country and what I try
to explain in my comments was the
benefits of buying time and the reduced
overall number of deaths because our
approach and our doctoring and our
therapeutics get better as we buy time
and we learn as
whose most vulnerable and where to put
all of our resources there are those
three studies that support that of
course any study can be criticized I
remember at the School of Public Health
and graduate school they would give you
ten research papers and your job was to
rip them apart regardless of how well
done they were and you can always poke
holes and the question is at what point
does it cross a reasonable level of
methodology where you believe that the
results are likely true and of course
many studies to meet that criteria I do
think we did flatten the curve and save
lives
so those are my general thoughts yeah
okay few questions dress to you and and
of course the normal recitation of the
few countries you mentioned Brazil but
as you probably know of the audience's
of course citing Japan Sweden South
Korea mainly I guess those three as
examples of a very limited lockdown
which and they seem to be doing about as
well as other countries and so how do
you react to that challenge how did they
get away with it take it away Marty
well great questions and first of all
I'll point out that Japan is still
dealing with you know that it's hard to
make conclusions when it's an ongoing
epidemic same in South Korea now South
Korea was able to do a terrific job
early on with contact tracing and
isolation and we know that has a
powerful effect and doctors tried to do
that in Washington State but they've met
all sorts of barriers with FDA
regulators about getting testing done
there's an excellent article written in
The Dispatch on the crazy regulations at
the FDA that prevented early testing
including one of the doctors in
Washington State being told he had to
resubmit his application not just
electronically but also by mail
including a cd-rom with the file
burned on the cd-rom and that we lost a
valuable six weeks because of those
regulatory shenanigans so South Korea
did a great job with it
now Sweden is an interesting story
because first of all Sweden is a
different population okay we have a far
more obese and comorbid population than
Sweden and I would say a far more
at-risk population Sweden you know we're
learning a lot of the drivers of this
infection and some of it is public
transit density associate economic
status the number of people living under
one roof we're learning a lot of these
drivers and some of those factors are
not as common over there just as they're
not as common in Oklahoma where we have
not seen the same level of transmission
as we have say in New York City Detroit
Chicago or Los Angeles so sweet'n is the
subject of a lot of criticism within
Europe and the idea of hey we'll take
our deaths upfront it really sort of
goes completely counter to the idea that
we as doctors are getting better at
treating kovat illness and the
therapeutics are on the way the
battalion is coming and so if we buy
time I personally believe that there are
there are benefits look at the vaccine
we didn't even think we'd be able to
come up with a corona virus vaccine that
had never been done before three months
after we started working on a corona
virus vaccine it's been shown to work in
rhesus monkeys it's been shown to make a
different virus altogether it was shown
to devote to be able to produce
neutralizing antibodies in human beings
so if now it's a matter of figuring out
the dose and the safety and the efficacy
and mass production but we're pretty far
along in a short period of time Thank
You Marty a good could you do comment on
the question that was just put to Marty
about your pee and got and there's also
hungry there is Iceland and the other
countries in Europe have not all done
the same thing at the same
and still most of them if not all go
down I actually comment the Swedish
government to have done something the US
government so far has not on and they
have admitted that keeping the nursing
homes open was an error and I wish
American politicians would also admit
that they make errors when they make
errors okay and that's it any Karen okay
a question then do you think
that these countries have like Sweden
have probably achieved herd immunity
Japan Sweden and South Korea because I
think we have seen that all over Europe
her demand we have seen that in most of
the United States and we will see it in
those corners where the virus come late
a bit later the problem is if these
states where the virus came later
started actually the mitigation before
they hit the peak they have a problem
but but you are saying again that in
most areas of the country including the
epicenter where you and I live not herd
immunity has been achieved and mayor de
Blasio should say let Broadway bloom let
let the movie theaters open let the
restaurants flourish forget social yes
you yesterday as possible and you're
caught walking around New York City not
wearing a mask
am I correct note and you why should I
wear a mask okay
a thing of obedience okay so you want to
go in most areas of the country you want
a complete lifting of the lockdown and
Marty what's your response to that
complete lifting of the lockdown well it
turns out the most important aspect of
the lockdown was it was it say it was a
vehicle to promote distancing at a time
when we did not understand how to do
distancing what the right distancing was
we didn't know the role of
asks we are you know even myself as
somebody who has worn a mask most of my
adult life as a surgeon now I spend most
of my time in public health and public
health research in public policy but for
most of my adult life as a surgeon I
wore a mask I was skeptical that a mask
would reduce the transmission of this
infection and it wasn't until I talked
to so many people around the world where
I really became convinced that the
droplet transmission even from speaking
breathing or shouting singing that
droplet transmission is a powerful
vehicle of the infection spreading and
if you can reduce that with a simple
cloth mask it's a highly effective
generalizable intervention that can be
done and in fact when I asked doctors in
China how have the Chinese medical
community how have they been able to
manage this infection in a country of
over 1.1 billion after 2 citywide
outbreaks in cities of about 11 million
how how could you possibly contain it
and their answer was Marty everybody
wears a mask and in fact it's true of
most of the Asian countries and in fact
if you saw somebody at a grocery store
two years ago wearing a mask at random
chances are they were Asian why because
it's an accepted part of Asian culture
we are now recognizing the benefits it's
just not been a part of our culture it's
not been a part of our medical teaching
when we talk about public health
mitigation of infections and so this is
something where I've I've come around
I've come full circle and in the New
York Times piece that I wrote I I
basically said we need to reopen at this
point as connect money money is never
okay that's like it sounds like you're
going into your summary so let me let me
just to clear your summary starts so
pick it up Marty go ahead well I was
just gonna say the basic points that
I've sort of come to and I do think what
canet said is important we need to be
humble I think in this country
we tend to get entrenched in a position
I even hear businesses tell me you know
we want to know what we should do right
now as a business and I tell them what
you do right now will change okay what
the policy that you should have for
customers the policy you should have for
people working from home could change
every day as the background level of the
viral burden changes as science learns
more about this infection so I think in
general we could use more humility in
healthcare I think we can learn from the
data better I think we as a country now
tend to get very dug into our positions
unfortunately we're seeing the sort of
political ization of this issue and it's
probably promoted by a lot of the social
media now right people tend to shout if
you look at Twitter it's all shouting
right and many people are shouting with
no information and no expertise I value
what canet is saying because he's
somebody with respected credentials okay
I want to learn from him I think if we
look at how we've talked about this
issue by and large going into it and
during it people have dug into their
positions and I think that has been one
of the problems and one of the reasons
why we've seen a lack of adoption of
mitigation best practices in some parts
of the country we've seen some local
governments act in complete disregard
for Public Health
we've seen some get lucky you know as if
their viral adji geniuses when in fact
there was a seasonality to this virus
that we were unaware of it was an
unknown going into this thing so you
know wearing masks is one of those
things where I have evolved my position
and along those lines businesses can
redesign their their business processes
we can encourage people to do things
outdoors we can encourage businesses
that can do things outdoors not
everything for not every business they
can but for many they can to encourage
that
and at the same time we need to focus on
those who are high risk in bulletproof
nursing homes so that's my overall
feeling on where we are now instead of
and to get away from the position of
today it's a lockdown or total full
reopening it's not it should be it
should be sort of continuum based on the
prevalence of the virus in a particular
community based on best practices and it
should be moving in the direction of
reopening with precautions being careful
Thank You Marty okay that you want to
conclude that your summary there you are
given seven half minutes to conclude I
just want to mention to you could've
before you I have been getting a number
of questions about the data and using
aside from the fact that you don't wear
a mask and Marty doesn't I'm my wife is
Japanese and I know that Marty is right
about people wearing masks in Tokyo
because I've been there and that's over
the years so that's absolutely valid but
aside from the masks questions have come
in about the data and so perhaps in your
summary you want to touch on the high
points of your data which seem to drive
your analysis about herd immunity and
about how the lockdown came too late and
it was not effective
take it away click okay first I would
like to mention the credentials I don't
want anybody to believe anything I say
based on my credentials I have made a
very big effort to put all the evidence
and the sources out there so that people
anybody who is interested can actually
look at the data and it is data that we
were trying to get as comprehensive data
as possible so that we don't need to
argue with a net article evidence and
personal experience I think if we want
to understand something as complex as
the dynamics of
[Music]
respiratory disease epidemics we have to
do hard work and we cannot rely on
anecdotal evidence and credentials of
people it needs to be scientific and we
have seen how dangerous it is when
people rely on credentials because in
the White House there are three
biologists and so I give credentials to
biologists even if they have never
worked on a respiratory disease and they
have no idea of epidemiological models
and the same is for businesses I can
feel that there is people are afraid or
not but if I see that in the city of New
York the tests of viruses are as close
to 1 0 percent as it gets to ask people
to wear masks at the time when there is
no virus around because fuzzy things
that is what we need to do to show that
we are willing to do the things that we
should do masks as a proof of
willingness to do the right thing is
something that I cannot support so I
think we should not talk about
willingness and obedience we should not
talk about what our personal fears and
experiences are when we are imposing
things on people we should do that based
on science and unsound and thoroughly
collected evidence and you have a fight
you have a four and half million more
minutes coats you want to go over your
data what do you want to do okay no I
think it is there's something else that
I have been said many times and I would
like to say it again if
we want to live in a democracy we have
to actually actively interact both of
others end with our representatives just
sitting there and letting the government
duel without questioning and without
them questioning the media where the
media are not custody because right now
the media are not questioning the media
are just regurgitating what the
government says I think if we want the
democratic process to actually function
we need to become active we have to ask
questions and we have to get engaged
just sitting there and being obedient
will not help with the progress of our
democratic system okay right all right
you're good in your concluding remark
that's it yeah okay that's it okay
thank you very much to you both for a
friendly and a spirited debate Jane
please open the final vote many who have
not seen this livestream have cast an
initial vote and will be viewing this
debate in a few days once it's released
on video and audio will be keeping the
final vote open to give them a chance to
cast the final vote the results will be
announced a week from today
you will take a couple of days thanks
you all for watching
thank you Marti Meharry and Knut
Witkowski for participating we'll
certainly have more online debates like
these but I hope to see you all at our
physical space as a subculture theater
and they're not too distant future good
night